no one is more chilling than rapper
cuevos assistant cuevo one of the
rappers of the migos there's three
members of the migos he pays his
assistant let's pull this up five
thousand dollars a day five thousand
dollars a day
there he is right there he's holding an
umbrella so
cuevo can chill in the shade that's five
thousand dollars to
hold an umbrella so basically if you do
some basic math five days a week let's
say he's working five days a week times
52 a week i know you're not a math guy
five times 52
is almost
1.3
million dollars a year cuevo's assistant
is in full where did i go wrong sauce
millionaire well we're about to find out
he's hiring like that let me know yeah
exactly well we're gonna ask this
question to the people
um here the article goes on
although
we are sure there is a lot of blunt
rolling and umbrella holding
his assistant joshua washington is also
the head of operations for honcho
records which is cuevos record company
uh by the way cuevo's estimated net
worth is 26 million
so he's doing all right
so
the overall biggest lesson here before i
turn it over to you guys is you know how
they say your network is your net worth
right i don't know this guy's story but
what a situation he's
walked into to make a million dollars a
year
five grand a day to just basically do
whatever cuevo asked him to do right hey
i need you to do this hey go do this go
get me a coffee go roll a blunt get me
my umbrella bring those ladies over here
i wonder how intense it is though is it
like at 3 a.m any hey come here so
that's the question that's the question
to our audience at home let us know in
the comments
for you guys right now for 5k a day you
better wake up would you do anything and
everything
that quavo or your boss asked you to do
by the way you're making a million
dollars a year
a million dollars a million dollars a
year you have to do it you're the best
person
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay bro